We are going to be talking about a number
of aspects of a weekend Republican donor event
that took place at Donald Trump's Florida
club.
Doral looks like Dorel to me.
I don't know why they say Doral, but if that's
what they say, I'll say it.
It took place this weekend.
We're going to talk.
Yes.
About what Donald Trump said.
But really, the relevance of Trump now is
more now that he's out of office.
The relevance is what happens to the followers
of Trump in the Republican Party because they
really are the future of the party.
The followers will decide whether it's Trump
or someone else at the head of the party in
2024, and they will decide whether these Trump
and Republican officials get reelected or
removed in 2022.
And so, OK, hearing what Trump says, fine.
But hearing from his followers and from Republican
donors, that's really the future of the party.
And it's unfortunately as bad as anybody could
have imagined.
We're going to look at an interview with a
woman that CNN spoke to in Florida at this
Republican donor event at which Donald Trump
also spoke over the weekend.
I was looking at this like the Zapruder film.
I mean, you you almost have to go frame by
frame because there is so much ignorance and
delusion and toxicity packed into a really
small amount of video.
So let's just jump right into the first clip.
And I do believe that the election was stolen
and I do believe that it was a peaceful rally
that day and that just because people who
were in the Capitol were wearing Trump shirts
and Trump ads doesn't necessarily make them
Trump supporters.
Anybody can get one of those shirts.
So that is merely 18 seconds.
And it is filled with ignorance that could
take months to overcome and change people's
minds about.
I do believe the election was stolen.
She says she's not alone, but I mean, she's
a nut, but she's not a lone nut because 60
percent of Republicans believe exactly that.
60 percent of Republicans believe that Donald
Trump was the rightful winner of the November
2012 election.
Now, December, January, February, March, April
were now five months out.
Sixty percent of them still believe that.
OK, that is not a fringe view.
There are you could have tens of millions
of conversations just like this one with other
Trump voters.
She says the Trump riots were mostly peaceful
and not really Trump supporters.
Half of Republicans believe that.
And the reporter tries to explain.
We know that they were Trump supporters.
There is no doubt when when we look at the
court cases, we find, you know, years of pro
trump social media activity.
At some point, you have to apply Occam's razor.
Did they two years ago, three years ago, five
years ago, knowing on January six they were
going to pretend to be Trump, let's start
falsely seeding SCD false pro Trump stuff
on their social media.
Or if it walks like a duck and it sounds like
a duck, it's simply a duck.
And she doesn't care when she's presented
with that.
Take a listen.
But a lot of them have been shown to be real
Trump supporters, very true indictments that
they've been a long, long time support of
Trump.
I don't know that to be true.
So this is really a case of burden, of proof.
She believes without evidence that the Trump
is that the riots were fake.
Trump supporters.
There's no evidence of that.
There is evidence that they are real Trump
supporters, but she hasn't seen it, so she
dismisses it out of hand.
This is a really big epistemological hurdle
to clear, and we've talked about it before,
very, very difficult.
And the most effective way is you build a
rapport with this person and over a period
of months, you can maybe get them to change
their view.
That doesn't work when it's 75 million people
that believe the stuff.
It's just just a fact of math, quite frankly.
Let's continue.
I think some people who watch this who are
not Trump supporters and others say here's
a Trump supporter who's in denial about January
six.
Would it not be better to sort of have to
say that to me?
Because I've had friends and family already
say that to me, you know, because they disagree.
They think that I'm crazy, that I'm a conspiracy
theorist because the election was stolen.
Now, that is fascinating.
She says forget about your audience saying
I'm in denial.
My family and friends has already been telling
me that for months.
And yet it seems to only further her belief
that she is correct.
This goes back to another principle we've
talked about.
Oftentimes when people are, you know, kind
of bashed over the head with facts, they don't.
They change their mind, they further attach
or align themselves to their beliefs when
they are told by others, that's crazy.
They don't say, well, maybe it is, they further
plant their feet in those beliefs and and
and that it simply doesn't work, as we've
talked about before.
Let's look at more of this.
Speaking of your family calling you conspiracy
theorists, Mergenthaler Green is going to
be speaking here this weekend.
She's known as the some is that she went on.
Congresswoman, I don't know what's so terrible,
terrible about Kuhnen.
Can you tell me it's a faceless conspiracy
theory?
Well, let's hope you know what is so terrible
about conspiracy theories anyway.
Can you tell me?
I mean, there's steroids.
There are conspiracy theories behind JFK assassination.
I'm old enough to remember all the conspiracy
theories that swirled around his assassination,
but it's always it's always painted in such
a negative way.
These conspiracy theories are are cutting
into the foundation of American democracy
or helping inspire a violent insurrection.
No, I don't believe that's the case.
And what way can you explain the delay the
election was stolen?
Well, see, that's where we part ways.
I don't believe that it's a lie.
I just love that you actually see if you're
watching how she seems to be back on the defensive
for a moment there.
But then she comes up with something that
in some Republican circles is what I call
faux enlightened, a faux enlightened.
You can always these are crutches.
These are I wouldn't even call them epistemological
crutches because there's no epistemology there.
It's a rhetorical crutch where you can always
say what's so bad about X anyway?
And that makes you, quote, open to quote ideas.
This is a really common thing that people
on the right who know enough to know, they
know that they don't really have facts, but
they also have these rhetorical crutches they
can put their weight on, like turning something
back on on the other person.
And then we get to what is now one of the
toughest problems that we're dealing with,
which is disagreements about what facts are.
Now, I've made this distinction before, and
it's a really important one to understand.
We're not experiencing a disagreement about
what the facts are.
We've had that forever.
We're having a problem of lots of people.
Don't know what type of statement is a statement
of fact and what type of statement is a statement
of opinion.
Much of right wing media is built on the fact
that their audience doesn't know the difference.
A huge portion of this country, particularly
on the American right, doesn't understand
that not all statements can be reduced to.
We have a different set of equally valid beliefs.
There are knowable facts and there are opinions.
But tons of Americans don't know how to categorize
those types of statements.
And there's really no easy recovery with that.
And I know it's like a broken record at this
point.
This goes back to education.
This goes back to media literacy, critical
thinking stuff.
You really have to start teaching around age
11 or 12.
I'm not saying that folks like this woman
are, in a literal sense, too far gone.
But if you've listened to the phone calls
I got on the show, if you've seen the interviews
I do on the show, you know, the level of work
that would be required to change one mind
for someone that is so indoctrinated like
this woman, imagine 75 million of these people.
That's why I'm not optimistic that these folks
are the ones we can necessarily bring back
in bulk.
It seems we need to do a better job of educating
people never to fall for this stuff in the
first place.
But it's going to be a very uphill battle.